foreign
Naya
governance
coffee shop
foreign
thank you
suppose
corrosion
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
hmm
yeah
days
big beach
yes
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
ladies and gentlemen
I would like to welcome you to the
coronation Hall of us City Hall
wholeheartedly to the conferral of the
international domain prize of our 12023
to the Ukrainian people and with its
president his Excellency volodimir
celinsky
today in the presence of this
minister of exterior the ladies and
gentlemen excellencies dear prime
minister moravieski
and they won't welcome to the
institutions of the European Union
the president of the European Parliament
Mrs metzola and the president of the
commission Mrs funderline
we are also pleased to welcome
the representatives of the
Constitutional institutions of the
German Federation
Mrs Bart
Chancellor Schultz
and minister of State wrote
and the president of the federal
constitutional Court Professor Dr
harbard
we welcome the excellencies the
ambassadors of Bulgaria Croatia
Lithuania the Netherlands
the United States of America
Latvia France
Ukraine and Poland as well as all
members of the Consular Corps
a very warm welcome
goes to the state of northumber's
failure and its state premiere of boost
State Parliament president Cooper and
the members of the state government and
the state Parliament
as well as the former Prime Ministers of
our state Jurgen Rutgers and Armin
lushit
a very warm welcome also to all members
of the German bundestag and the European
Parliament
it is a great pleasure for me to welcome
the numerous former Charlemagne prize
laureates Among Us Mrs Dalia gribus
Cuete and Martin Schultz
as well as last year's laureates mrskaya
Veronica
who represents her sister Maria
calleznikavahia
a warm welcome goes to the
representatives of the churches in faith
communities and especially to the
Ukrainian Nobel Peace Prize Laureate
Alexandra madvichuk welcome to aachen
I welcome the members of the bodies of
our Charlemagne fries with former Lord
mayor Dr Jurgen Linden as the chairman
of the board for the conferring of the
Charlemagne prize
since the attack on Ukraine in February
2022 which is uh in brief I mean breach
of international law we have been
talking in Europe about a turning point
in time the Ukrainian people who have
been fighting for their sovereignty
since the end of the Soviet Union
who've always been clearly committed to
the liberal and democratic values of the
European Union
and who have been striving for
membership in the European Union since
the 1990s are being hit hard by the
consequences of this turning point this
brutal Russian war of aggression against
Ukraine has been going on for over a
year now and many of us have already
become accustomed to it to the Daily
reports of Terror arms deliveries
to ever new threats from the Russian
side
but as much as this news has become part
of our everyday life it remains our task
to make sure that the people who are
directly affected by this war are not
forgotten
it is our duty to constantly remind
ourselves that in our Europe a whole
people is being denied a life and Peace
and Freedom
an entire generation is being deprived
of his childhood youth opportunities and
dreams
that is
why we should remember especially today
that there are individual Destinies
behind each of these horror stories
on the occasion of conferring the
Charlemagne prize to you your Excellency
solensky and to the Ukrainian people I
would like to take a moment to reflect
on the situation of some people off the
big political stage today
in Ukraine and also here here in aachen
and to give them a face and a voice they
deserve this
to these people
present today
they represent the association of
ukrainians
both women
when the war started immediately
recognize the giant tasks lying ahead of
us and together with other committed
citizens they founded the association
ukrainians
both women have been living in Germany
for a long time and in aham and since
this war started they've been in
constant fear worrying about their
parents siblings and friends in Ukraine
since the war their lives have changed
completely with great Passion they
helped to find accommodation for a
Ukrainian War refugees collected and
transported humanitarian aid supplies
and called for demonstrations
in the meantime this has developed into
much more the association organizes
language causes is committed to cultural
exchange and wants to preserve Ukrainian
history culture and tradition as an
anchor for the refugees
and at the same time wants to
familiarize our citizens with them
ukrainians in aachen is today a reliable
partner for All actors thanks to the
sustained efforts of its Founders the
association has contributed to making
our city a safe haven for war refugees
from the very beginning and for this we
would like to thank him wholeheartedly
one of them is Julia grimnova
with her children and her husband she
was one of the first Ukrainian Refugee
families to come to aachen and I would
also like to welcome her especially
warmly today the story of Julia grenova
and her family is representative of
countless others
forced to flee the Homeland once before
due to the annexation of Crimea in 2014
the family was able to build a new home
and a new life in butcher near Kiev
until history
was repeating for them cruelly with
Russia's renewed Invasion once again she
and her children had to leave the home
in a hurry
but already on the run the next horrible
news reached them
while trying to leave butcher which had
been occupied in the meantime the car of
Julia's parents was shotted by Russian
soldiers
her mother died
her father survived seriously injured
and although Julia
has experienced immeasurable suffering
and her family's future prospects are
still extremely uncertain she has been
tirelessly involved in humanitarian Aid
since her arrival in aachen and she
advises people who want to flee Ukraine
together with her sister Oksana she
founded the initiative sokil in Ukraine
which evacuates old and disabled people
from the front and has thus already
helped many people to find a new home
and to survive
also with the help of the association
ukrainians
family has integrated here learned a new
language found an apartment and
schooling for their children
however her husband has returned to help
on the ground
like him the entire family has not given
up Ukraine it is still their Homeland to
which they want to return
many ukrainians feel the same way as
juliova and her family
therefore after providing immediate
support from the beginning it was our
special task to offer the people in
addition to the said save Haven
perspectives beyond the war
this enables them to enjoy a life and
freedom again here with us or in their
Homeland
together with countless organizations
initiatives associations and volunteers
we have created these perspectives and
will continue to do so in future
side by side an indirect exchange with
the ukrainians
be it on a local level
as just described on a national and
international level or on a municipal
level within the framework of the
solidarity-based city partnership
we are currently building such a
partnership with cherniev a city in the
north of Ukraine which in addition to
its current population and
infrastructure has another parallel to
uh to aachen
obeyed to the aachen that the founding
fathers of the Charlemagne prize
described in their proclamation of 1949
and they described it as follows after
two world wars in which the Border
situation of our city had a particularly
detrimental effect in which the honest
efforts of several generations to
overcome imaginary National antagonisms
proved to be in vain
our city which has sunk into ruins
is struggling for its right to live
Justice
today to a large extent destroyed
therefore we enter into this partnership
not only to express our unconditional
solidarity in this way
but above all to support cherniev and
its inhabitants in their efforts to
rebuild their city as a sustainable City
and to make it their home again
our concrete Corporation will start
tomorrow with the representatives and
I'm so happy to have the Lord mayor from
sharonif amongst us
the fact that the possibility of
returning home still exists
that families like Julia grenovas can
still dream of a future in Freedom in
their Homeland
and that people whether in Ukraine
throughout Europe or here with us still
have any hope at all for an end to this
conflict would probably not be possible
without the men whom we are honoring
today together with the Ukrainian people
with the Charlemagne price the president
of Ukraine volodomir Selinsky
shows courage leadership
tactical sensitivity
and he demonstrates a new clear and
unambiguous political style the citation
reads among other things and further
he is a support and also a role model
for his people he stands against
hopelessness and despair and for the
confidence the goal of a free
independent and Sovereign Ukraine which
is part of the European family of
Nations zelenski gives strength to
Ukraine but also to the European Union
to believe in this ideal
in this respect he's also a role model
for all Europeans to remember European
ideals and values
all of you sitting here today document
by your presence
that Europe can be relied upon
as I've just described
we are assuming our responsibility by
preparing together for the time after
because as you president zelenski hold
your people together and give them
strength and confidence in the greatest
traces
you show us with your personality and
determination
not only how we can stand together for
Europe and freedom
but you also give us confidence
that you will find a way together with
us in the same way to give the Ukrainian
people a peaceful and Democratic future
We Stand By Your Side
by the side of the Ukrainian people
foreign
s of the of Ukraine
dear president zelensky the followedemia
dear Lord mayor kuipen
the
chairman Dr Linden dear Jurgen the
president of the commission dear Ursula
the Prime Minister the Mateus ladies and
gentlemen
president
toots
those were the words
the Mr President volodimir that you said
quoted in one of the first video
messages concerning the Russian invasion
of Ukraine the president is here we are
all here
uh on in the early early in the morning
of the 25th of sept of February 2022
this is when you said this
together standing in the center of Kiev
and you added
all of us will defend our independence
and that will be how things remain
it's very rare in in history that such
brief words have had such an effect it
was immediately clear the Ukrainian
people will not give in to Russian
violence the Russia Ukrainian people
will survive
and it's for this reason alone that we
can be together here in akhan today
Europe has
a lot to thank the Ukrainian people for
any particular this president Mr solanki
when the founders of the Charlemagne
price in 1949 came up with the idea of
the prize many parts of Europe were
lying in ruins the
terrible experience of two World Wars
the violations of human rights hunger
poverty and security sadness were all
very present Europe living in Peace and
Freedom was a vision for the for the
distant future however the founding
fathers of the
charlem and price saw their dream
realized more and more each year
the list of Lawrence reads like a who's
who of European integration it ranges
from Jean Monet Conrad I don't know
Robert Schumann Seymour certificate
and brandish love academic
men and women who have been driven by
courage to push ahead with what many of
us consider to be a matter of course the
peaceful development of Europe that
makes the prosperity and peace of our
people possible in the first place but
today once again we have a terrible war
of aggression
Russia's terrible war of aggression a
war which for the people of Ukraine is
painful demand sacrifices like we could
not imagine a war that is against
everything for which Europe today stands
and also a war that which for the U for
Ukraine for Europe and its member State
shows very clearly we are standing
together we belong together and our
history will carry on together
For the First Time The Charlemagne prize
is being awarded this year to a
president and to his people I think this
isn't an exceptionally clever decision
because
the Ukrainian people and you my dear
volodimir
together starting on the 24th of
February 2022 you have been achieving
unbelievable things tremendous bravery
your dis you're defending your
land with a tremendous bravery against
the aggressor Russian every day people
are defying the Russian aggression
through their efforts Russia's war of
aggression has brought Ukrainian people
and Europe together like never before
solids We Stand Together in solidarity
either side of Ukraine Germany has taken
up more than a million Ukrainian
citizens Poland has taken in over one
and a half million and Czech Republic
over 500 000. the number of Ukrainian
German twinning associations has doubled
and throughout Europe the war has made
one thing very clear
Ukraine is part of the European family
um as France's president said Italy's
then prime minister Mario draghi
Romania's president Klaus Johannes and
myself when we visited Kev together we
emphasized this and we stand by the
statement again today
Russia and Ukraine are not one people as
President Putin claims in his
imperialistic and colonialistic rhetoric
the Ukrainian nation has its own long
history it's unbelievably diverse own
culture its own Traditions its own
identity
following the breakdown of the Soviet
Union ukrainians have been fighting for
the right to determine their own future
themselves and Ukraine has taken its
decision a decision in favor of Europe
zelinsky
on the road to the European Union the
Ukraine will have our full support as
Europeans we know what
energy
is in Incorporated in a democratic will
of the people I think about uh
solidanish in Poland the opening the
fall of the Berlin war in 1989 brought
about by courageous citizens of the gdr
and then the unification of Germany and
Europe in the Years thereafter and of
course I also think about the orange
revolution in Ukraine in 2004 and the
winter nights in the Well Done in 2013
2014.
during this revolution of dignity the
blue yellow flags of Ukraine and the
blue and yellow flags of Europe became
symbols of the freedom and
self-determination of Ukraine all of
these popular movements demonstrate the
strong will of people to determine their
own Futures themselves Russia's war of
aggression has not only
strengthened ukrainians will as a
political Nation it is also
strengthened the will of the Ukrainian
people to become a European nation
if
Vladimir Putin believed that he would be
able to bring the bring Ukraine away
from its path with his violence and all
his tanks his uh his rocket missiles
have brought about nothing but the exact
opposite
the European Union stands for peaceful
coexistence up by the people of Europe
for the political and economic
cooperation between our member states
and for the beauty of cultural and
linguistic diversity the European Union
stands for freedom and democracy for the
rule of law and protection of Human
Rights and in particular for the
um for for reconciliation between
previous enemies I'm very well over very
well aware of this as a German
chancellor and that's what
distinguishes us as Europeans therefore
every day we must pay attention to
ensuring that the values of democracy
freedom and peace are maintained even
within the EU this striving for
democracy for rule of law for freedom
is also shared by the Ukrainian people
dear Vladimir
Servants of the people this is the claim
with which you began your role as
president of Ukraine
and you are precisely that today
when it comes
to receiving the Charlemagne prize on
behalf of your people the resistance and
the desire for Freedom uh Inspire hope
well beyond Ukraine
at the
head of the Ukrainian people you defend
the values for which Europe stands the
Europe the ukrainians can rely on our
full support humanitarian economic
support weapons and above all in the
long term
in 1986 the luxem the people of
Luxembourg were the first people to
receive the Charlemagne prize the text
on the medal said the people of
Luxembourg rolled middle and
perseverance on the way to a unified
Europe's phrase is just as applicable
today to the people of Ukraine so
today's conferring of the Charlemagne
prize does not represent an end point
but a beginning the start of a new
growing together in Europe together with
Ukraine with the west Western Balkan
States Moldova Georgia
given the change in Return of the times
our message is clear Europe
is United and together the Charlemagne
prize as a prize for European citizens
means the Deep respect of our free
societies
towards the bravery and courage of the
Ukrainian people and their president
all right
the Ukraine is here and
Ukraine is Europe
congratulations and Slava Ukrainian
foreign
dear president valenski diwaladimir
Chancellor Olaf Schultz prime minister
muravsky the
um
mayor Elizabeth dear Dr Linda ladies and
gentlemen
when you enter the city hall
you are and look at the wealth of
ancient landmarks and monuments you can
almost feel with all of the senses the
weight of European history its violence
and its beauty
it's pain
and its progress
it's centuries old divisions and it's
decades young Unity
this prize
as the founder cut Pfeiffer put it
embodies an obligation of the highest
ethical value to make the next chapter
of our common history better than the
last one
that obligation is for a strong union of
Europeans quote to
defend the highest Earthly Goods freedom
Humanity
and peace
and Safeguard the future of the children
and children's children unquote
the person and the people that we are
recognizing today
have lived up to that obligation that
any one of us ever could
they are literally Fighting For Freedom
humanity and peace
they are a bleeding and they are laying
down their lives to safeguard the future
of their children and of ours
president zielinski and the people of
Ukraine know
exactly what they're fighting for
and they have understood what Europe and
our Union is all about
my words cannot really do justice to
this
or far from it but those of President
zelensky can
in his remarkable inauguration address
in 2019
he told the people of Ukraine
and I quote we have chosen a path to
Europe
but Europe is not Somewhere Out There
Europe is here
in our minds and after it has appeared
here once it will be everywhere all over
Ukraine
unquote
president zielinski the uhladimir I am
firmly convinced that your those words
will come true and we will not stop
working to make sure they do
ladies and gentlemen
the uh story of pain comes with strength
and courage Ukraine has shown this every
single day since that fateful morning
when Russia sent tank columns and tens
of thousands of soldiers across the
border
when I met volodimir zielinski in a
shell shocked Kiev a few weeks later
in the government
neighborhood I had just come back from
butcher
I had just seen the mass Graves next to
the church the body bags lined up
tightly together the early cruel symbols
of Putin's War
I will never forget the image of those
innumerable candles everywhere Each of
which represented a mother or a father a
son or a daughter
a brother
or a sister alive
senselessly extinguished
people's feelings were Despair and anger
but they also had a firm belief the
belief that Ukraine was fighting back
and turning the tide
when I spoke to president zielinski in
those early days I called him many times
and I knew about his courage and his
determination in those Bleak early days
but on that day in Kiev when I looked
into his eyes for the first time I was
deeply touched by this steadfast
determination he exuded
president zielinski had enhanced the
unshakable belief that those fighting
for something will always be stronger
than those fighting to impose their rule
and this is why
because of this courage and this du
opination the the victims and the values
I cannot think of a morph be fitting
winner of this Charlemagne prize than
president zelenski and the people of
Ukraine
president zielinski and the people of
Ukraine are fighting for exactly the
values and the obligation that this
prize embodies and in doing so they're
also fighting for our own freedom and
our values democracy and the rule of law
free speech
and the freedom to create your own
destiny
this is what Ukraine is fighting for
and this is what President Putin is
trying to extinguish
President Putin is destroying the work
of peace that we have built together
since the end of the second world war
later after the fall of the Iron Curtain
Putin aims to destroy the Europe
created by Charlemagne price laureates
such as gilahon and wachlav Havel
Francois and many others
Putin tries to unravel the events of
1989 and the decade since
which saw the people of Europe tear down
the Iron Curtain and Europe changed its
face forever
as historian and Charlemagne Prize
Laureate Timothy garton Ash put it so
well
every generation has its moment
when it has to stand up to defend
democracy
and what it believes in
for us this moment has come
and just as the courageous Freedom
Fighters changed the face of our
continent in Europe a little more than
30 years ago today it is us our actions
that will decide what our Europe will
look like in future
the Ukrainian people have revealed to
the world the strength of their society
their will to fight and to be free this
has amazed the world there and collects
certainty
where they belong is fascinating
it's an inspiration for all of us for a
decade the Civil Society people in the
Ukraine have been the architect of our
Ukraine's move towards the European
Union
and never can we match the sacrifice of
The Bravery of the Ukrainian people but
we can stand firmly by their side
I'm not just talking
about the tens of billions of Euros of
support to Ukraine the sweeping
sanctions against Russia or the modern
weapons and ammunition that we have
pledged and delivered
I am also talking about accompanying
Ukraine on its path towards our Union
and getting it ready for the future even
though the war is Raging I'm thinking
also of the countless Europeans
who've opened their homes and their
hearts for Ukrainian refugees four
million people
have found a temporary shelter after
leaving their Homeland because of
Putin's bombs and I would like to thank
and recognize the many volunteers
I would like to pay my respect to the
cities and municipalities the teachers
and sports clubs who integrated
Ukrainian children into their groups and
the countless Enterprises that gave work
to their parents this is Europe at its
best
ladies and gentlemen it is thanks to
president zelenski thanks to the people
of Ukraine and thanks to all of us
sticking together that Europe's face is
changing once again
Ukraine incarnates everything the
European idea is standing for the
courage
to stand in for one's convictions the
fight for values and freedom
the commitment and the struggle for
peace and unity this is why I'm
convinced
that Ukraine will prevail it will win
peace and make its European Destiny come
true as part of our European family
dear Alexandra might be joke
you a few days ago
in Vienna said the following and I quote
people in Ukraine want peace more than
anyone else but peace does not come when
the country that was attacked lays down
its weapons that's not peace
that's occupation
and occupation is just war in another
form just as bad as War unquote
you are so right
in our EU we speak many different
languages 24 of them
but in all of them
Victory translates as peace and justice
just peace
as has always been the case with Europe
there will be Skeptics saying that it is
impossible it's a fantasy
but if if what if this is in fact our
duty our task to unite and make the
impossible possible
Against All Odds those words are again
from president zelenski
where you speak of the victory he said
when the guns fall silent and people are
raising at their voices
unquote
he was back then talking about Ukraine
but these words also describe Europe and
what it stands for our Europe
so what if
this
was our idea
if it was our task of our Europeans to
stand together and make the impossible
possible
with today's prize we are sending out a
clear message
We Stand by the side of President
zielinski we stand by the sigh of the
people in Ukraine We Stand by their side
until we together achieve the impossible
Slava ukraina Long Live Europe
um
thank you